[Music]  at this point in the season it's getting  damn cold out there  and you're gonna be wearing a lot of  things that are a little bit more toothy  as we say  [Music]  you want to really honor the fact that  this is the winter it's getting freezing  cold and you're starting to put layers  on and you don't want some floppy silk  tie  it can also be a great basic for fall  can be your best friend with a white  shirt it can go with a bold plaid shirt  it can go with a striped shirt and I  guarantee if you have a simple gray  tweed tie it will go with everything  important  [Music]  a wooly tie is great for business you  can wear it with a semi spread collar  shirt and sometimes the wool is even a  little bit of cash Meredith it's gonna  tie a beautiful tie the dimple is gonna  stay on the knot  I'd have to say put the silks to the  backyard roar you gotta wear a tweet I  [Music]